what i want to do in this video is show
you a very cool video and then pose a
question but i want to make sure that
the video everything's up and up on the
in terms of the copyright laws so the
video i'm going to show you is from a
show called the fifth gear that appears
on channel 5 i believe in the united
kingdom and i think i'm okay on good
copyright grounds to claim fair use here
because obviously the point of this i'm
going to ask a math question about the
video that we're going to see and so
fair use laws the purpose and character
of use including whether such as a
commercial nature or non-profit
educational purposes we are definitely
the latter non-profit educational
purposes we are actually the we we
aren't trying to in any way replace the
work being used i'm just going to show a
little snippet of it so we can use it as
the basis for a problem and this is kind
of the meat of fair use law reviewer may
fairly cite largely from the original
work if his design
if his design be really and truly to use
the passages for the purpose of fair and
reasonable criticism in this case its
fair and reasonable math problem or
physics problem on the other hand it is
as clear that if he thus cites the most
important parts of the work with the
view not to criticize but to see
supersede the use of the original work
and substitute the review for it such
will such a use will be deemed in law a
piracy so in no way do i want to
supersede it you should go look it up
you should watch the show this is not
good enough i'm just i don't even have
the sound on and it's going to be a
little small little window here where
i'm just going to show this really
really the the the part where they
actually do a loop the loop now with
that out of the way this is where you
can find more information about fifth
gear
which is on channel five now let me
actually show you the video i'm going to
have the sound down
and so this is the video right over here
it's a pretty neat video this guy is
going to attempt to do a loop the loop
and he's actually going to succeed at
doing the loop the loop and what i want
you to do and the question i want you to
pose is look at this video and get a
stopwatch and get work get it whatever
else you need out a ruler or whatever
else you might need to do and try to
figure out what we're going to do two
things we're going to figure out what
the minimum velocity that the car needs
to complete the loop and we're also
going to try to figure out what his
actual velocity was over the course of
the loop the loop so let's actually just
watch this video
so there he goes he's starting he's
accelerating toward looks like he's just
crossed almost he's pushing almost 40
miles an hour at least i'm assuming that
was miles per hour this is a british
show
and then he
hits
he hits the loop the loop
and then he finishes it and he's done so
let's think about for the next video
let's think about if we can figure out
what the minimum what the minimum
velocity or i should say the magnitude
of velocity or speed had to be to
actually complete the loop right over
here and then we can actually get a
stopwatch later on to figure out what
his average velocity actually was